[Musique]
le moyen-âge comme si vous y étiez le
temps d'une journée le centre-ville de
Mantel Jolie s'est transformé en village
médiéval jongleurs cracheur de feu même
les animaux de l'époque étaaiit à
l'honneur on présente des animaux
anciens qui existait au Moyen-Âge on
fait des déambulations avec les oies et
donc notre ferme itinérante se dans les
fêtes médiévales dans les fêtes à thème
les épades les centres de loisirs et on
présente en fait des race d'animaux
anciens au public on explique un petit
peu voilà leur origine leur façon de
vivre et donc ça permet par exemple aux
citadins qui n'ont jamais vu d'animaux
de de pouvoir les approcher et que
serait un village médiéval sans ses
chevaliers pour rendre l'immersion
totale la compagnie Les galots de
l'histoire propose des démonstrations de
jeux équestre nous on a une spécificité
pour les jeux équestres on fait
travailler nos dames donc on appelle le
jeu des dames donc en fait c'est des
jeux qui était pour s'entraîner soit à
la guerre soit à la chasse et donc ça
permet au grand public de voir comment
au 12e 13e siècle on entraînait les
cavaliers à l'URE de la guerre ou à
l'heure de la chasse puisqueà l'époque
la chasse prépare à la guerre et donc
puisque le le le défi final c'est
évidemment d'en revenir vivant donc ça
permet de s'entraîner sans s'entretuer
créé au 15e siècle pour mettre en valeur
le commerce et les traditions de la
région comme la vente d'oignon très
importante au 19e siècle la foire
continue d'attirer les visiteurs grâce à
ses nombreuses animation une façon de
faire perdurer dans le temps le
savoir-faire et l'histoire médiévale
c'est bien parce qu'il y a un peu de
tout à voir il y a un peu toutes les
activités tous les métiers aussi de
l'époque donc c'est sympa de voir un
aperçu de tout ça c'est super faut faut
pouvoir encourager aussi des gens qui
qui participe à à préserver un petit peu
t tous ses savoir-faes donc c'est
vraiment génial on passe un super moment
épreuve que l'esprit d'entant continue
de fasciner cette année encore la foire
aux oignons a accueilli près de 4000
visiteurs